he's just hitting like tennis balls and
like c-stands
oh yeah yes
this is the real vfx talk this is the
vfx act that happens behind closed doors
after hours
this video is sponsored by skillshare
stick around to the end to see how you
can get a free trial of a premium
membership
what up pimps is vfx arts react your
favorite series your only series that's
what you hit the bell for
i'm with my two bros sam
and nico the people i learned visual
effects from so let's take a look at
some of those videos and let's take a
look at some of the movies that helped
define our love of visual effects
he's back in it it's one of the greatest
drift shots of all time here oh
yeah oh you feel that
this is i put this shot up there with
the jet shot in transformers
there's some shots just the way the
camera moves has like a momentum to it
and like an expectation of where the
elements are within it
you don't climb into a t-180 to be a
driver
you do it because you're driven racing
this is
the car's number one frame
you do it because you're driven oh
so cool whoa that's kind of trippy
actually
i never i've never seen that detail this
is the beauty of 24 frames per second is
the human eye can still catch
one frame if you just flash an image
that's an animation thing right that's
an anime thing
i would say by the way spider-verse has
the same love of
animation and applying like these visual
techniques
you know so much why don't you tell me
why i should keep driving
that's for you to figure out
so beautiful there is this is breaking
and there's no like realistic anything
happening here right it is completely
emotionally subjective this is not
something that anyone's seeing right
like
it's completely untethered from realism
it's
expressing the emotional momentum of the
scene
through imagery oh you go back you flash
back to the beginning
you flashback to oh this is a kid and
then you're gonna come around and get
more morph into the yeah
it's so good it's just like the way
they're transitioning seamless with
each shot here like so constantly like
they're not using cuts it's like
half of the cuts aren't cuts man i wish
more movies were made with this kind of
like kinetic energy
that's the thing i think about a lot
actually is is in a lot of these movies
it's about the kineticism of it like the
rack of racket guys happened yeah in the
space
and i think about like when you look at
a racket record video compared to like a
marvel fight scene
it's like yeah the marvel fighting might
be more technically like choreographed
but like
it's just there's more impact it hits it
feels like it
feels like you're getting thrown like i
don't i can't explain it it's something
that you like
feel
i think i saw this one like six or seven
times in theaters one of the few movies
that the approach to visual effects
wasn't how do we make just something
realistic period
the perspective of it was like how do we
redefine
how visual effects can create a visual
language
this is like the amount of coordination
it takes to be like a director and put
this together because most directors
don't have their heads wrapped around
motion graphics
and most motion graphics artists don't
have their heads wrapped around
character dialogue in like
scene beats and pacing like to be able
to bring all this together is such a
work of mastery it's storytelling and
visuals
together better than almost any other
film has achieved oh
my goodness if somebody watches this
sequence
and comes out of it being like it was
okay whatever it's like i don't want to
know that person
i don't if this scene doesn't move you
then
movies aren't for you go find something
else at entertainment read a book
this is pure cinema are we going to
watch solfar's videos
that's the clip i i don't i can't find
it that's it
i can't i don't even know how to search
for it i found it no
yes so here's the thing before we even
met each other before like we were all
15 years old and we were all on this
like fx home website this was like the
one
hub for amateur visual effects artists
and that was like the very very
beginning yeah we're all like all in
middle school we're all like loading up
after effects version
for our parents cameras yeah we're all
borrowing paris cameras and this website
was the place you upload your cool
vfx action videos there was one man
the god blind man the god of this
amateur visual effects website
he still continues to make movies and
videos to this day
he was known as soul farm
aka marco von moose when we all watched
this video
we all melted into our scenes
you're telling me on my home pc i can
make an action movie
this cool
[Music]
dude oh my god
but then they overlapped hitting each
other why is he hitting himself
[Music]
whoa the matrix look how big the board
is he stops it
[Applause]
dude that wow so how about the truck
shot how do you guys think we did the
truck shot
was it a model yeah yeah these are
hot wheels
that this one was a comp right but no
they're both they're both
perspectives yeah he's holding it in
front of the camera yeah
that's not oh it's not even positive
it's just yeah it's just a toy
dude i just realized that gun shot where
he flips the gun up with his foot
he's just he revert he just reversed it
he went bang bang bang and then dropped
it on his foot i think
and by the way good muzzle flashes like
there's still i see muzzle flashes in
like commercial movies that are worse
than that still
[Music]
maybe use a green screen who knows
probably not considering you could
barely green screen with genie
so dv footage is 720x640 is a weird
aspect ratio that gets squeezed back
into a 4x3 while you might have
720 by 640 pixels of black and white of
luminance data
you had one quarter of that in color
data so if you filmed on a green screen
you only get a 320 by 240 resolution
image
for pulling your green screen keys so
the moment you start doing a green
screen key for a full screen shot
there's like
big cubes just missing on the side of
your actor and they had like all these
like
hacky like oh we got a way of smoothing
it in the software and you do it you
turn the slider all the way up you're
like
you're like how do they do it in
hollywood man
absolute legend could you imagine by the
way like you sitting around with a
camera nowadays people like oh yeah
i'm doing for instagram do them for
youtube could you imagine this man in
austria or wherever the hell he is on
the side of some industrial road
with his camera like doing this the
bystanders what would they say
we hear listen we hear about people at
home who are like hey you guys got me
into visual effects you got
like this is that for us yes that's all
because
one man made this yeah that's that's the
crazy part
one man could pull this off and we were
but one
man each and it gave us the
motivation and the inspiration
machines control your life right now
everything
what you buy what you watch what you eat
those are
all machines robots you saw terminator 2
take control of your entertainment away
from the machine click subscribe
this is an arrow when you didn't have a
lot of friends so you did have to just
fight yourself
it's like oh remember that jetly movie
the one
what's this jet li doing this is what we
said this is gently making a movie by
himself
right we're back to so far here justice
is gently doing so far
so this is bad gently right yeah yeah
[Music]
oh so cool what a great effect this is
like the only bullet time ripoff to
still be like
rad yeah you're right
oh you take the power dude yeah his
power dude
okay so that's the plot he gets more
powerful each time he kills a clone yes
this shot oh yes
yeah dude he's so strong alright so
here's the thing
everybody had their minds blown and
you'll probably mind blown too because
this came out what like 2001. those were
all cg doubles
in 2001. there's when they're making
this like how are we going to do this
shot like do we film people in slow
motion on a green screen and comp them
in
it's like okay we'll do it this way
we'll just kick the stuntman around meet
him with a club a little bit
just kick him in the freaking head he's
like we could use padded clubs but no
let's just kick
it's just torture and you're like it's
it's all right
it's not bad we could just try to do in
3d
no one's really done this before yeah
he's just basically hitting like tennis
balls and like c
stands and it's just him walking around
doing power moves in like an empty
room the thing that they that helps them
a lot is that a lot of times the
animation is what gives away
the digital devil right yeah having slow
motion where we have no context of where
the movement should be
like going to slow motion and then kind
of hitting fast and all that stuff like
that helps it's funny the only part that
gives it away there for me is when
afterwards see the guy like pulls his
head out yep right
yeah when they're getting up we're like
oh that looks a little more cg right
something just i just caught something
that's actually really impressive
the flashlights on their guns are
shining lights around the scene you can
see them
lighting up the floor oh [ __ ] you're
right wow
that shot would not look nearly as
realistic if the floor wasn't replaced
doing the floor replacement lets them do
appropriate shadows reflections
flashlight reflections all that stuff
and then visually that's half of the
shot right there yeah
wow good on them bravo
hey tell me do you beard or no beard
leave a comment
i've been thinking about it longer
shorter beard no beard
i want to know from you i judge i do
everything in my life based on what
the comments say on this video so i want
you to tell me what to do with my life
beard or no beard also also uh if
there's any movies or cool videos that
official effects you'd like us to break
down
please leave a comment uh actually add
it to the beard comment
under the beard comment
this one oh man a little premise here at
the very beginning of our youtube career
freddie and brandon had lost her channel
you guys been doing it for maybe
eight months sam and we're finally
launching our channel and we made this
minecraft video
and then collab with you guys on this
mario kart video this was
and that's what and that basically
pushing from this to the minecraft
videos what launched our youtube career
what a weird world we live in
i remember the shells being so impressed
by how good these shells look just that
shiny surface
because you know what is what's nice
about it is that you have the you have a
reference for like a shiny reflective
material yes
in this plastic of the go-karts so when
they come out just like
oh whoa so sam and i were like really
trying to step up our vfx game
and for this one in particular we're
like all right let's do all the things
the pros do let's take an
hdri light sample of the of the place so
our lighting matches
let's do fully like physically based
materials for the objects and lighting
let's do physics for the 3d stuff so
that it animates well
i really like this part where they miss
and it's a physics simulation
yeah they just kind of hang out and also
if you look we've moved we moved this
side thing and they
that's right that's right that's right
yeah yeah yeah yeah we removed that were
you back there you
yeah what was this background to get the
real oh i remember that yeah
that's there was quite a bit of work on
that one if i remember right
the moment the shell hits we transition
to
a digital 3d rendering so it was a
really like you know low res kind of
you know janky model but it didn't
matter because it's
it's getting motion blur to hell and
then the only thing that needed to get
fixed there was the helmet the head
there so that's the only thing that is
a little bit separate yeah it's like a
ball it's like a weird sphere that goes
on top
you see the three shadows too like we
have down like our elements in the group
that's right so a lot of these shots
were again we didn't really the gopros
weren't good at the time
a lot of these are just like me hanging
off of the front of these dan cam
or or brandon hang on like you can
sometimes see our arms like hanging back
with a big wide lens
by the way i still have a scar from this
shoe oh really yeah yeah i think i was
driving i think
you were driving i was on the front and
i was holding the camera and then nico
nico decided to take the turn a little
hard and so i got thrown off the back of
it
and i still have a scar on my hand for
when i
fell onto the ground man sorry
okay and there's our minecraft video
dude the ad revenue from that minecraft
video paid our rent for like three
months
to be fair our rent was pretty low
it's eighteen hundred dollars a month
split five
wait five ways you don't know why we
were able to quit our jobs and just do
visual effects and not eat anything and
like and like
use the oven to heat our hands cause we
paint 300 bucks a month
10 a day you spend more on that
starbucks
that was on rent back then so if you
want to get a youtube career
live in a shack seriously
what is up ladies and gentlemen on this
channel we are all about
learning and education and developing
new skills
and because of that i want to talk to
you about today's sponsor skillshare
it's been a crazy year so far but with
skillshare you can make it
a year of growth and personal
empowerment because a site like
skillshare offers you
a membership with meaning you have a
community of like-minded passionate
individuals driven
developing their creativity or their
knowledge in all these different areas
and you can join them
skillshare offers classes that work for
you and your real world schedule
everything is broken down easily
accessible in the different lessons that
you can complete on your own time
now you might think because this is a
filmmaking channel that will be pushing
filmmaking lessons on skillshare but you
know what they have
lots of different lessons for example
investing so you can start planning for
your retirement
instrument lessons so for example they
have handpan lessons i even didn't think
they'd have hand pan lessons because
it's such a unique instrument but they
do
so kudos to them for that and of course
you have all of your
different creative lessons as well which
are very very well done and useful in
fact
one of my favorites is the davinci color
grading list that they have it's an
overview of how to do great color
grading individually in a good workflow
for pulling in from other programs the
first 1000 people to click the link in
the description below will get a free
trial of the premium membership
and if you decide to continue with your
membership it's very affordable it's
actually less than 10
a month if you sign up for the annual
one so yeah
good stuff go get learning turn your
quarantine time into poor
corn me time and start learning a new
skill
at skillshare
hey thanks for joining us on this visual
effects
it was a lot of fun yeah this is a whole
this is a blast for you thank you this
is a blast
and a blast from the past it's really
fun looking at a really old stuff and
stuff that inspired us too yeah like
sharing a little bit of that story with
everybody here on youtube because
youtube's changed so much in the past
decade
year every six months is a different
youtube
pretty these days if i want to be
entertained by you where do i go
i'm doing a podcast there's a podcast
called dungeons and daddies it's a
dungeons and dragons podcast but we
don't play it too well
and it's about four dads in dungeons and
dragons
land trying to solve things it's a lot
of fun all right
freddy see you later see you later
freddie
visual effects of stairs back here boys